all right welcome to another edition of
a beginner breakdown I am your host Mike
color today we'll be going over what to
do when you get on tilt has anybody here
played a poker before it's called tilt
when you make a mistake and then the
mistakes just keep compounding okay it's
just one mistake after another so we'll
see games where you know somebody makes
a mistake and then it all just goes
downhill from there but there's ways as
we'll describe coming up how to how to
minimize the downfall okay so here's a
game I play it against one of my
students I have the black pieces against
Jaden okay so he starts out with the
move efore I counter with E 5 and so
white brings his knight out to attack
the pawn so we need to defend it Knight
to c6 okay and so now White has a couple
different options he can go into he can
attack the knight with Bishop to b5
obviously this is the rori Lopez and try
to take the knight and give black double
pawns or he can play the move Bishop to
c4 so Bishop to c4 this Bishop is now
attacking this vulnerable pawn on f7 why
is this pawn on f7 so vulnerable right
because only the king is protecting it
and as we all know Kings cannot capture
protected pieces so very very vulnerable
square here so if you've been going to
my lectures you know a move I would
never make here and that move is Knight
to f6 which would allow the
I live or attack if white would so
choose to go into it and now there's no
way I can defend this pawn
besides Queen to e7 I would have to play
the move d5
okay so so I play the move Bishop to c5
and so white gets castled
I played my knight out to f6 and now
when Jaden plays Knight to g5 which is a
mistake what move can I do to you know
just get an advantage so I could play d5
here so after pawn takes I can play
maybe Knight takes or maybe ninety five
but I don't really want to get into all
that so what's a really easy way well
there it is what's a really easy move I
can play to just defend f7 which is
obviously castle because you saw it
right all right so you give this castle
and so now after Knight to c3
I play h6 the knight gets out and now I
play d6 so so if you look at this
position with with J and moving his
Knight back and forth and he being the
white pieces see it looks like he's only
played one two three four five moves
while black has played one two three
four five six seven so if you're going
to do an attack you should just go for
it instead of wasting all these moves
okay so very disappointing for a llenar
if you're not going to go follow through
with the attack you should be able to
calculate and not do it in the first
place you don't want to play home chess
hello you bring some of your games today
all right we might go over one later
okay
so now white plays the move h3 to
prevent the move Bishop to g4 because if
you would play just a random move this
could be very obnoxious but this could
this pin could be very obnoxious he
would probably have to bring his bishop
back to e2 to to break it so so h3 and
now decide to trade the night for the
bishop so the bishop is attacked in this
position what move would you play as
white here so d3 is what is played but
it kind of gives you bad pawns you know
you know you got double pawns and this
pawn is not looking so hot
anybody else have any other suggestions
besides d3 Joe okay so so so Joe is a
little bit better than your average
beginner in me so he suggests I'm not
going to give up the two bishops and
I'll play Bishop to e2 so I I would
probably play that move so if Knight
takes pawn takes but then you do have
double pawns again but you got this a
file open but after a six not looking
too good okay so another way to protect
it is Queen - E - so after Knight takes
Queen takes will attack it again
and then you'll just have to retreat but
you know if you don't want double pawns
Joe suggestion is the best and you keep
the two bishops but as a mr. Lee
suggested right
d3 is what it was played and taken now
you got these ugly pawns
alright so attack them and now the Queen
defends the the pawn here alright so so
I get my a pawn up which looks like a
weird move but I don't want him to do
the same thing to me with night a4 and
train off the bishops so a5 a3 so Knight
to h5 so that looks like a weird move
and it is a bit of Hope Chest but what
am i threatening here which it really
isn't even a big threat anyway so if I
play Knight f4 he'll probably just take
it right and then I'll have double puns
so I don't want double pawns this really
isn't even a threat here notice that the
the F pawn is in a pin here so it cannot
move out of the pin so this square on g3
is not defended but I mean he would just
play rook to e1 and he'd be fine anyway
so I don't really know where that Knight
is actually going but it's just
something to think about for later if he
ever plays Queen to e2 or something then
I would get the fork but
far far away reason right yeah it's
Joseph
it was a great strategical move yeah
that's me for you that's me right okay
thank you thank you
alright so so he's he's gonna try to
stop it all with Bishop to e3 so capture
and he takes with the pawn why did he
not take with the Queen can anybody see
why he did not take with the Queen hey
why didn't he take the pawn with the
Queen I why I did he why did he not play
Queen takes III oh yes mark there's no
real rule like that
I mean sometimes it all just depends on
the position what is the Queen doing in
this position that it would not be doing
if the queen is on e3
well the d6 - X isn't in a pin because
it'd be an even trade but the Queen is
doing something very important on d3
right now
yeah he's protecting the pawn on c4 so
so we have to take with the F pawn if he
wants to keep his C pond and he does
well he does have doubled pawns but you
would rather have double pawns
than no pawn on c4 yeah okay so now he's
got he's got some more weaknesses that I
can try to try to attack so Queen to d7
so he thinks maybe I'm threatening
Bishop takes h3 and Queen takes O so if
he would let me do it do you think this
is good for black who say who's voting
yes all right so we got it we got some
yes we got two yeses back there all
right very exciting very exciting so so
what is the the big threat what's
black's threat here that close to it
close to it so let's see so so usually
when they do this when they sack the the
bishop for the two pawns usually a real
natural move whether you're white or
black is to retreat the night here but
would it work let's see what the
computer says about this my vote is
white is good well yeah and of course
the a says play Knight H - uh-huh
okay so
it's just a half a pond yeah so it's not
well considering
but there's other factors to take into
play here as his pawns are garbage here
and I have you know to pass pawns here
as well if if this pond was on on the F
Square on the F file
I think the evaluation would be way
higher for weight Bensimon where do i
press to get back okay thank you and so
so Jaden just prevents that he doesn't
want to play you know defense and get
checkmate it so he just plays King to h2
so a for-real attacks so now the Queen
or this D pawn is in a pin right cuz now
if I would take he would get two pieces
for one so I get out of the pen yes mark
so all right so I get the Queen out of
the pin and now I've got two players on
the pawn here so what should white do to
defend the pawn here
be three I don't think b3 is gonna work
why does b3 not work in this position
take it just take it
yeah and then you take back but then I
get rook takes all right all right you
just like oh it's a double pawn I don't
even need it anyway well look how bad
this is gonna be if he just lets me take
this okay
Bishop Queen rook all in a lane bad news
so you probably do want to stop this
somehow any other suggestions b3 does
not work yes mark yes so so he needs he
needs a good another piece our pawn
defending it so it's two two and then I
won't be able to take it because I need
more attackers than defenders in order
to take something so right now I'm up to
one but but it's his move so he can get
somebody on it or he can walk possibly
yeah Joe about 90 to 92 might be the
best move but it's not what Jaden plays
but 92 is looking pretty good
well well I have to prepare f5 because
notice he's got one too with to the
x-ray at three and I only have two but
yeah but I could I could I could start
preparing it though it's definitely good
definitely started preparing it let's
check it let's check out what the
computer says here okay well let's see
what he's got
so they're both about equal but Jane he
decides I'm gonna go on the offense and
play Knight to d5 so what is the big
threat in this position if you're
playing black what is the threat because
if you don't see this threat you lose
the game just like that 97 with the
super 4th right boom boom so so there's
a lot of different moves I could play
that I was considering like rook here
maybe even Queen back but I decide just
to just to just to get rid of his threat
and take I want to see if that is the
best
well what oh yeah they're saying they're
saying if Bishop takes d5 is the best
move here so I and there of the other
alternative was Queen to c5 that way I'm
not getting fork so I take now usually
your first instinct is the best what is
your first instinct of how to capture
this pawn here Wow well ok so so he says
he says the wrong answer but for the
reason so he's like I want to get rid of
my
double pawn so I'll take back with the
the C pun but you see how much uglier
these guys are then then these guys I
would definitely take with the epon
alright Sabatini saying the C pawn
alright alright let's have the computer
be the judge
alright I would I want to see all hands
we got we got about we got to be got
some players there everyone see Ben
Symons hands okay I want to see who
things taking back with the C pawn I've
got one when you set it so you should
one two three four and then one two
three four five you're on the e pawn
right all right all right so then we
have so so it's really split so I guess
here comes the engine it'll not be Queen
takes so a takes d5 gives white a small
advantage uh-huh
while C takes d5 gives black a small
advantage excellent all right but but
Jane of course plays Queen takes d5 and
so I obviously I don't trade here
because I don't want to let him get rid
of one of his double pawns so I play the
move Knight f6 attacking the Queen and
so he takes and I have double pawns it
double puns are the worst thing in the
world if you know what to do with them
okay so so now what is under attack of
whites here there's the e pawn right so
as Joe mentioned earlier Knight d2 has
to be played here I mean it just has to
be you have to you have to you have to
protect that point but I guess he
doesn't realize that
and he plays c5 trying to give me
tripled pawns but but I take okay so so
this is a kind of the point of the game
here okay so so we saw we watch the
whole game right and it's been pretty
close all the evaluations as we've gone
through it's been pretty much you know
either white has a slight edge or black
has a slight edge but nobody is crushing
anybody you know I mean he's got these
double pawns but but that's not he's not
gonna lose the game because he has
double punch so so we've been very even
throughout the whole game but now okay I
took one of his double pawns and he's
probably down by maybe you know just a
half pawn here based on the evaluation
point five okay so there's no reason to
really panic or anything but as you'll
see he lost the pawn it shocked him and
he can't recover so if you ever get a
position like this in a game right where
oh man something unexpected happens
especially if you have you know over
twenty minutes on your clock you know I
would just you know maybe get up from
the board take a deep breath a couple
deep breaths maybe get a water or
something and then just come back and
then when you come back to the board try
to look at everything that is under
attack of yours so so you don't just
start losing more and more material okay
look look it look at every one of your
pawns is anybody attacking that point is
anybody attacking that point and really
see so so now in this position right
which which piece are pawn of White's is
under attack here c5 right you just
played c5 right all right and for some
reason you know he lost it eeep on and
he doesn't realize hey so now this is an
easy move here take with who
you do not want to take with the fight
you're not going to shuffle funds in
this position so you take with a knight
right all right and now now he's mad
again all right so now he's just lost
two pawns in a row so when your man
you're gonna make some more mistakes so
he can't wait to attack my knight big
mistake
cuz what move do I have on pissant right
whenever you move up to and it lands on
the same row guess what on passant can
happen okay so so you know a lot of
mistakes but you know what
there might be one more mistake coming
so now he just can't make a mistake
after mistake after mistake Oh
so after c-4 instead of c4 obviously he
should just take this pawn he's got to
you got to stop the bleeding so take
take and now rook F 2 so quadruple air
here so so what move can I make now to
just keep the punishment on rook takes a
three right how easy okay
so he went from being even for the whole
game and now if you look at the
evaluation you don't even want to look
at the evaluation I'm up by like a
touchdown here right because this guy is
going to turn into a queen so Knight
back I can't take anything for the first
time ever
so now rook a - so I see this a lot in
games whenever the rooks are attacked
you know and it's undefended
you know usually oh I gotta take you
know he could he could play rook here he
could defend the rook he can do a lot of
different things okay so so just got
somebody's attacking your rook with the
other rook and your rooks on defend
doesn't mean you have to take you know
there's a lot of different moves you can
make but okay so obviously takes takes
Knight protects the queening square my
knight attacks the queening Square King
up
rook gets behind the pawn Knight up
Knight takes rook takes and now the game
is pretty much over
I'm never going to move my work off the
a file right because that would be
dubious I'm not just gonna give them a
pawn I don't even want to trade a rook
for this I don't want to trade like if I
play there
take take you would never do that
because there's no reason to you would
just keep the rook behind the pawn it's
very simple
push the other pawns and and you know
whenever he takes take back with check
and then you know you just bring the
King up and March and get and get the
get the Queen okay all right so that's
that was that game and now here's a game
of our everybody's favorite player
Mario Roper all right and Mario has the
white pieces in this position okay so
here we go so he starts out with the
move key for black counters a five so
Mario just goes right for it right away
Bishop the c-4 attack the the F pawn
here Knight f6 attacks the e pawn so
Mario protects it knight c6 a4 okay so
so this is a common theme sometimes you
know you do not want to trade this
LightSquared Bishop for this night okay
as we saw in the last game so a4 so if
he ever tries like 1985 we just bring it
back to a two okay
so Bishop the c5 attacks the F pon so
Mario brings his Knight out
so black plays a6 probably not the best
move
probably Castle is best a six because
Mario is really not
gonna put anything on b5 that looks like
and black can't even get in the move b5
so really no reason to play a six so d3
and now now as we saw in the last game
right Knight to g4 so who thinks that is
a good move good because it's not it's
not a good move at all
so obviously white should just cast
right and now obviously just in case you
don't know at home or anything if he
plays Knight takes f2 our Bishop takes
up to check well always just take with
the rook Bishop takes King takes and
then we'll get two minor pieces for a
rook in a pawn and then we'll be a
massively in development and we'll have
more pieces than him so it's good it's a
good trade even though it's six the six
based on the points but that's what we
would do okay okay so black plays the
move d6 and now Mario thinks he has a
trap here so when Mario's gonna try it
okay so all right but somehow Mario is
gonna make this work okay so so
hopefully everybody knows what black
should play here and it should not be a
mystery right you should all be yelling
it castle right castle right but
unfortunately his opponent plays the
move Bishop to e6 yeah what massive
blunder
because what is that what is that Bishop
doing on c8 that's so important right
now
protecting the knight right so so a very
simple tactic right remove the defender
remove the guard Bishop takes pawn takes
Queen takes
and now black is in trouble so you're in
trouble but you know maybe you can try
to try to hold on here okay because it
doesn't look like blacks gonna play very
good from here on out
so what move where we play here so we
just lost a whole piece but it doesn't
mean we should just you know play really
bad do we have any suggestions here for
black to try and hold on or well castle
castle castle would be really bad here
because Knight takes e4 oh wait so black
is actually gonna try to recover here
and play Knight to d4 so he protects the
pawn here but it doesn't matter right
because because it'll take take check
queen east seven alright so so this is
Mario playing okay so you know Mario you
can have a really really big lead and
still lose right so if I was boreal in
this position I would I would take Queen
takes Queen check okay but Mario's like
no my Queens better than your queen I'm
on the offense I'm gonna hold on to my
clean and make a threat here so okay but
if if you if you play Queen takes Queen
here it's gonna be really tough for a
black to recover cuz you'll get uh
you'll get a check in and no you can't
play the F pawn but but you know you can
just stop any kind of back rub checkmate
with g3 or something and then you know
he's got no hope yeah I allow no counter
playing just and just it's gonna take
you you know thirty moves to probably
win the game but whatever alright buddy
but
what's a quick knockout okay so he's
attacking the b-pawn so he defends by
castling so now Mario attacks the Queen
Queen moves alright so so now Mario gets
maybe he's preparing before here so rook
rook and Bishop we're working together
so Mario doesn't like so Bishop e3 some
takes double pawns are really
insignificant here so I would probably
play that to open up the rook but but he
is a place place safe so c6
so now b4 so now notice this C pawn
isn't a pin so you just want to attack
it
Brooke f6 so yeah and as joe says it's
always fun to look for a 4c moves those
are those are things where you know
you're threatening captures and checks
and uh all kinds of cool stuff yes
right so you're threatening the rook so
if the rook moves uh-oh Knight to b6
check and then the king and queen are
gone okay but Mario is just he's got his
plan going with the b-pawn so he's just
gonna keep it going
so now King to c7 as we see is a not the
best move because now we just have the
tactic straight up Knight d5 check King
out Knight takes G takes rook b1 b6 all
right so now Mario thinks he's got his
opponent in a mating net and he probably
does so all right so now black is going
to try to get his own checkmate going
here
hey Jo
okay so so Joe's got a crazy-looking a
tactic here check King takes check queen
only legal move take it's pretty good
good enough but even if even if you
don't see it I mean but you should be
thinking about checkmate less Mario is
so he plays queen - a - threatening
checkmate alright so the only way to get
out of the checkmate is probably to move
the King alright so he does so king c8
and then it's gonna be the exact same
thing but Mario is even better he's not
even thinking about getting the Queen
here he's thinking about checkmate so
after Queen e6 check King up how do we
finish them off here Queen takes d6
check he has only got one legal move and
yeah everybody see the mate bring the
rook down and game is over
checkmate so Mario actually uh prevails
and also it's a good job Mara he's
getting better he's getting better yes
mark I would think around the thousand
level at least White is a thousand I
don't know what black can't be blacks
got to be pretty close to that level as
well
alright you you have a quick game we can
show here we got we got time for one
more quick one am I gonna be able to
read this there's a lot of scratch outs
alright sure mark okay
all right so you have the white pieces
in this game all right so so white
starts out d4 black plays d6 c4 Knight
of 6 so III so what what why do you
think I don't that like III you
voluntarily boxed in your Bishop I had
no reason to do that okay
you could play Knight to c3 right and
then if he plays g6 here you can just
play E for right big center okay all
right so III a little passive so g6 now
Knight c3 so try to try to play play try
to play these two guys out and then
Knight to c3 and then then you can see
chose a three is just too much of a
committal move okay you know you're
gonna play Knight to c3 one way or the
other so you might as well get them out
first okay
all right so nice III Bishop g7 Bishop
d3 this is a good spot for the bishop
so he gets castle you're gonna try to
get cancelled bishop attacks the night
but you know no reason to panic so we're
gonna just get castled now he brings his
knight to c6
so h3 try to break the pin so obviously
he does not want to go backwards so
he'll take and queen takes and now he
plays d5 so we have a lot of different
options in this position so we could
take or we could push I know what I
would vote for push yeah push but
so you play d5 and he plays Knight takes
d5 here why did he do that oh well
that's a that's a thinker for you so so
you just take you know if your opponent
makes bad moves you know just punish him
for it don't don't try to analyze don't
don't offer him a take back or anything
just you're out all right all right so
now he's like I do not want to trade now
what does he take in this position is
there anything he can legally take and
takes d4 oh you're the one with the
notation so uh so he just plays bad and
bad and bad well that's uh when your
until the stuff they get off a tilt I
guess I guess that's miss Lamor haul
ahead story but yeah so so you played
okay you didn't do anything spectacular
but your opponent blundered and
blundered and blundered and blundered in
and you won good job all right and you
got it oh yeah everybody good show
all right you got one more you got one
more all right
yeah well yeah it only last huh 11 moves
oh yeah why not sorry you got the white
pieces again alright he's the hero so II
45 Bishop c4 and now your opponent tries
Queen h4 here okay so so let's take a
survey real quick here okay so
I know what I would play let's hear from
the audience what would we play here
horrible it's even worse than the move
you played where we got Knight c3 right
yeah they c3 develop get a piece off the
back row protect no g3 is the worst move
you can play because you lose the rook
right but he decides to play Knight h3
so Queen takes check Queen e2 Queen
takes and you are in a lot of trouble
Wow you are in a lot of trouble I see
one move I don't even know how I saw it
what's the only only move he can play in
this position or else you know his queen
up one right yeah protect the night
through an x-ray do you see queen f1 no
no this is like a slaughter one man one
man came down and just slaughtered you
Queen h1 Chuck kingi too but the funny
thing is I don't know who's gonna win
this game
alright so what what does black have to
play here and if anybody's this Knight
of 6 you're out by boyhood excellent
because it protects the bishop yeah
Knight f6 might actually be the best
move in this position no obviously the
best move in this position is check and
take the bishop obviously but g6 is
played check 97
and so he's like I'm not going for the
rook I am NOT going for the rook I think
you're gonna he's there he's coming down
with the night he's coming down it's
very exciting so so if rook g8 is played
Bishop takes King Bishop takes Knight
Knight up 7mate obviously yeah all right
so all right good move then all right so
so what is he going to play here
we're g8 obviously okay do we have
anything better for black besides rook
the g8 I mean anything's got to be
better right because you get checkmate
d5
Oh d5 excellent cuz the Queen is
protecting it and well the night the
night is kinda he's pretending sometimes
you know just pretending and black is up
by haha ten points Wow okay so very
interesting so this is a this is a this
is a real thinker of a game so alright
so after rook g8 obviously it falls to
the the mate as we've seen before well I
guess black does not theoretically have
to take here right
so black could play what Knight to c6
here or d6 try to get out of this
checkmate let's see what the computer
says
d6 d5 doesn't that like Knight to c6
though why doesn't he like Knight to c6
yeah let's see what the computer says I
love the computer oh he's like oh all
right but all right so d6 is the best
move obviously he plays the worst move
and he gets checkmated so that was a so
much fun let's let's see this one more
time all right so white plays efore a5
Bishop so Queen here so yeah as Claudio
says Knight to c3 d3 is fine come on
but Knight our duo g3 is horrible Knight
h3 is horrible Queen f1 oh you do not
play Queen f1 in this position right you
you try your own thing and it works I
guess
somehow someway even though he misses
how to win the bishop right off the bat
here it's so funny that these kids they
play these openings and they know how to
destroy the opponent with it but they
have no idea how to defend it it's like
coma on and now now you don't take the
rook you go for the mate and it works
all right good job that's the one that
gets you the trophy that was the first
one and you have one hour with a
five-second delay how long does this
take five minutes five minutes minutes
okay
very well good job everybody thank you
for coming to another edition of
beginner breakdown and tomorrow I'll be
teaching mastering the middle game so
back-to-back Homer
alright see ya